zoom at the same time i'm looking at
chat
after a year of teaching remotely i'm
finally beginning to learn these basic
things
all right so
week six welcome welcome back
i know that uh um
that some folks struggled with the exam
last week
and so i want to take a minute at the
beginning of class today to
ask you uh if there's anything from the
exam that you'd like to discuss
i have to tell you we're not done
grading the exam yet
and uh we're hoping to be done with it
by thursday although
i can't promise that that will
definitely happen we'll do our best um
but in the meantime uh we can take a few
minutes today to talk about any
questions from the exam that you you
might have found confusing
so i'm going to devote a little time at
the beginning of our agenda to that
today to that
um so if there are any questions that
you thought were confusing
um uh just
um maybe put the question number in chat
and then i'll we'll try to get to them
and then we're gonna jump into some new
stuff
so we're going to talk for a little bit
about
total order and
determinism
a favorite topic of mine
we're going to talk about consistency
models
and this will include a few consistency
models read your rights
fifo
causal and strong we already talked
about strong consistency a bit
uh last week and if you looked at the
assignment three spec you already read a
little bit about causal consistency
so we'll discuss that today
and then we're going to come back a
little bit you remember last
tuesday we talked about a couple of
strongly consistent replication
protocols we talked about
primary backup replication and chain
replication so we're going to talk a
little bit about dealing
with failure
in strongly consistent replication
protocols
um that might be all that we have time
for today but if we have time
that's going to lead us in really nicely
to our next topics
which are consensus
and the flp
result so this is a pretty ambitious
schedule so i don't know if we'll get
here
but we'll get there if we have time
all right so let's start by giving a
little bit of time to
exam review so i have a couple of ideas
for questions that i think we ought to
discuss but
before i just launch into those are
there any questions that you think that
i should prioritize
let's say that we just have if we if we
only give say 10 minutes to this
which questions do you most want me to
talk about
if any i mean maybe you don't have any
questions from the exam
uh the causal broadcast one yeah okay
so we'll talk about causal broadcast
and we'll see how we do on that
i think there's one or two others that
were challenging but um
we'll jump into that first okay let me
just bring up the exam so that i have it
here
by the way i got my first or rather my
second i got my second
uh vaccination yesterday so
i'm feeling shockingly fine right now i
thought i was going to be very sick
today and
i actually feel okay maybe a little
tired but um
let's face it i'm actually tired every
day because i'm an assistant professor
with a toddler
so um yeah i actually feel okay
i don't have any fever or anything no
promises that i won't suddenly
start having a fever and start
hallucinating during class but
um right now i feel okay
okay so let's look at this causal
broadcast question
from the exam
so i think this was question let's see
nine maybe
i'm waiting for canvas to load
i use a password manager in my browser
and apparently the password manager
makes canvas especially slow to load
so i think it was i canvas is actually
being very slow but i think it was
something like this so i think we had um
one process that sent messages something
like this
and this was called m1 so both of these
were message one
and then we had a message here
which we'll call m2
and then we had a message here which
we'll call m3
so the question was
if all the messages in this execution
were delivered right away
after being received then this execution
would violate
causal delivery so the question was
what would happen if you used the causal
broadcast algorithm that we talked about
in class
to try to make this execution observe
causal delivery so try is a key word
here
uh because it turns out that you cannot
quite
use the causal broadcast algorithm that
we discussed in class to make this
execution
observe causal delivery why can anybody
tell me why not
what is it about this execution that
makes it so that you can't use our
causal broadcast algorithm to do that
good yeah somebody well okay somebody
just said
actually i don't understand what
somebody just said somebody just said m1
is not going to m3 so these are
let's give these processes names so it's
a little bit clearer
that's right messages need to be
broadcast messages
so these two messages here message m2
and message m3 aren't broadcast
so because they aren't broadcast
messages
causal broadcast won't work so the
causal broadcast protocol that we talked
about
actually only works if all the messages
in the execution are broadcast messages
but the question was what if you tried
to use causal broadcast like what would
go wrong here if you attempted to use
causal broadcast in this execution so
some people didn't see this they didn't
notice that there are messages in this
execution that aren't broadcast messages
and um so they you know tried to carry
out the algorithm anyway
and you'll get partial credit for doing
that because um that's i mean that's
what the question is asking for it's
asking what happens when you try to
carry out this causal broadcast
algorithm
turns out it won't work or it won't it
won't give you what you want
um so in what way does it not give you
what you want well let's have a look
so okay so first let's say p1 sends this
message m1 and this one is a broadcast
message note that it goes to everybody
it goes to both
uh p2 and p3 so the message arrives over
here on p2
um it's going to have a vector clock of
one zero zero
it gets to p2 is it deliverable
sure if we think back to what needs to
be true about this message so it's got
to be
so p2 p2 is going to have a a vector
clock of all zeros to begin with right
so this message is one bigger in the
sender's position
and it's less than or equal to the uh um
so sorry let me explain that a little
better the vector clock on the message
is one bigger than p2's local vector
clock in the center's position
and the uh in every other position it's
less than or equal to
so that's fine we can go ahead and
deliver that one
this one's gonna have a vector clock of
two zero zero
and that one's deliverable also because
this vector clock on process two gets
updated at this point right
after we deliver this message so now
once again
it's one bigger in the center's position
less than or equal in every other
position so that's fine
most people got this um that i've seen
most people figured this out they were
totally fine on understanding
what the vector clocks were on message
one and message two here
and that they were delivered right away
on p2
now let's again these aren't broadcast
messages so something's gonna go
wonky at some point but let's let's keep
trying to do this to try to figure it
out
so here's m3 what's going to be the
vector clock on m3
well at this point p2 has delivered two
messages so it's vector clock is is two
zero zero
it's going to increment its vector clock
before sending the message so the vector
clock on this message is gonna be two
one zero
and most people got that that i've seen
also not everybody but but a lot of
people got that
message gets over here and most people
saw that this message wouldn't be
deliverable right away
because p3's vector clock starts out
with zeros
they see that we get this message its
vector clock is too big
so they saw that most people saw that
this message is not deliverable
uh when we get here so this message uh
gets queued
this is where people started to run into
trouble so some people said
well then m3 shows up and then this
message gets unqueued and can be
delivered
but here's the thing look what look what
happened when m3 was sent
when m3 was set it was sent after
m1 and m2 both were received and
delivered at p2
so notice this two right here in the
vector clock of of
m3 that two represents the fact
that these two messages causally precede
m3
so m1 and m2 both causally precede m3
so it's not enough to just deliver m1
here
m1 will show up it'll be delivered
that's fine a lot of people got that
but that's not enough to deliver message
three because
message three is waiting on m1 and m2
and if you look at the conditions for
delivery that's captured in those
delivery conditions because
uh the vector clock on the message that
you're trying to deliver has to be
it has to be exactly one bigger in the
position
of the sender and less than or equal to
in every other position well after this
m1 gets delivered you're still only at
one zero zero so you still can't deliver
this one
you still can't deliver m3 and what's
more you're never going to be able to
because process three over here is
basically waiting forever
for m2 to show up but m2 is never going
to show up because m2 wasn't a broadcast
message
so what we were looking for on this
question was we were looking for you to
get the vector clocks on the different
messages a lot of people got that
we were looking for you to see that
message three got queued here
and then furthermore we were looking for
you to see that message one can't ever
be delivered at process three
because process three is waiting
endlessly for this m2 that will never
show up because it wasn't broadcast
so there's this is a question that that
i think a lot of people
got part of but from what i've seen not
too many people got all those pieces
um and uh so it was a tricky question
um i admit it was a pretty hard one i
think it may have been the hardest one
on the exam
all right how are we doing on time um i
don't want to
spend a huge amount of time on exam
review because uh because we have a lot
of other stuff to get to today
so so let me
pause there and see if anybody else has
any other exam questions that they want
to talk about just really briefly
going once going twice
the snapshot question yeah okay um
yeah that was another tough one okay
let's talk about that one really quick
i think we've already spent more time
than i said we were going to spend on
exam review but that's okay
stuff's important so let's talk about
the snapshot question
this is the chandy lanport snapshot
question
so we had something like this we had uh
three processes
and we had a snapshot where
each process's state had been captured
let's see i think it looked like this
okay so
we said that this process we'll call it
p1 initiated the snapshot
so p1 initiated the snapshot it snapshot
at its own state
it then sent out marker messages so
it sent one like this we'll do a
different color
i wanted to do the wavy lines which is
how i normally
draw marker messages when i'm drawing on
paper i want to do the wavy lines on the
exam too but unfortunately the drawing
tool that i used didn't
support that so i had to do dotted lines
instead i hope it wasn't too confusing
um okay so marker messages went out
um
this is what the snapshot looked like
here
here's what the snapshot looked like
okay so there were kind of two parts to
this question one question was
what's wrong with this snapshot
and the other question was this why was
why would this not happen
so the first question is easier i think
so
so um just really quickly will somebody
tell me what's wrong with this snapshot
f is not included right so there's a
event here
f but f is causally before d and d
is in the snapshot and we know that a
consistent snapshot is one where if an
event's in the snapshot
then everything causally proceeds it
ought to be in the snapshot too
so that's a problem right it's a problem
that f is in the snapshot
so how would you fix it well one way to
fix it would be to you know if f
were in the snapshot another way to fix
it would be to leave
d out of it out of the snapshot and
somebody just said
the problem was that uh some uh
processes didn't send their marker
message uh so that was part of the
picture too
but um in the picture the marker
messages were still in flight
so after um after p3
uh took its snapshot it sent its marker
messages out
and likewise here after uh p2
snapshotted its state it sent its marker
messages out so those were shown as
being in flight in the picture
um so the problem wasn't that not enough
marker messages got sent that wasn't it
right so that so the issue for what's
wrong is that this is an inconsistent
snapshot because we can see that there's
an event in the snapshot
d here but not everything that's
causally before d
is in there so if you were to take this
snapshot and show it to somebody
uh and you know they would be pretty
confused because there would be an event
happening here but not everything
that may have caused that event was
there so
why would this not actually happen
so this will this comes down to
something that we know is
a an assumption that the chandelier port
algorithm makes which is that
channels are fifo so messages from one
process to another
have to be delivered in fifo order
so that means that this marker message
right here
that goes from p3 to p2
this marker message here would have to
land up here
because according to fifa order it would
have to get
delivered at p2 before this
application message from ftd so
the snapshot on p2 would have actually
been this
which would have been a consistent
snapshot
and the reason for that is the fifo
requirement so
again right here
so this message may indeed have been
slow this marker message from p1 to p2
but by the time it got there after d
this marker message would have already
had to have gotten here
from p3 to p2 and p2's behavior is just
to take the snapshot when it first gets
a marker message
so the snapshot that i showed earlier
couldn't happen because of fifo
so that's what's going on there
if you have other questions about the
exam
please stop by office hours and ask us
um we're aiming to have the exam
reviewed by thursday we'll do our best
and um in the meantime uh
i'm happy to answer any questions that
you might have about the exam
and i'm sure that the rest of the course
staff is too so come talk to us
all right let's move on to the rest of
our agenda because we have so much to do
today
so first of all before i jump right into
the the material
welcome to the second half of the course
give yourself a pat on the back
you're done with the first half of this
course congratulations
so
the midterm is behind you
whether or not it went well you did
great
in the sense that you're done so
congratulations you're already done with
the first two assignments
the second two assignments are still
ahead of you
yeah so on to hard mode right
the second half of the course is going
to be harder than the first i'm not
going to lie to you
the second two assignments are harder
than the first two
and um i think the material will only
get
more subtle and interesting from here
but you have you've laid all the
foundation that you need
in order to understand the stuff that
we're doing in the second half of the
course
if you struggled with the materials so
far now is a fantastic time to come talk
to us and get help
because we're here to help
all right so
let's talk a little bit
about one of my favorite topics
which is total order
versus determinism
so some of you remember uh the picture
that we've drawn before of an example of
a
totally of a violation of totally
ordered delivery
and my favorite way to do this picture
is to pretend that we have two
clients
of a key value store
and they're both sending messages to
replicas
let's say the client one is writing
to the key x with the value 3 and let's
say that another client is writing to
that same key
with a different value
so what what goes wrong here well the
issue is that
different events happen on different
replicas in different orders
so replica one is going to get this
update saying that x is 3 first next
they're going to get the update that x
is 4 so
it's going to end up thinking that x is
4. replica 2
is going to get those updates in the
other order it'll first get the message
saying that x is 4.
then the message that x is 3 will come
in
so that's not great right these are
supposed to be replicas that means
they're supposed to agree but at this
point they don't agree
[Music]
so imagine for a second if we had only
one replica
remember we talked about how the
informal definition of strong
consistency is that clients can't tell
that the data is replicated right so
if you wanted strong consistency
one way to do that is to just actually
have only one replica
so let's just say there's one replica r
so what could happen here well
if client one is sending its update it
could happen like this
and then we'd end up in the state where
x is four right
but it just as easily could have
happened in the other order right maybe
client one's
message landed a little bit later
and then we'd be in this state where x
is three
so those are two different runs let me
be clear
so maybe this is a run where the message
landed here and then this other run is
when where the message landed here
so even with just one replica
which probably shouldn't even be called
a replica in this case because there's
just one of it
it's possible that these messages are
going to arrive in different orders
and there's not necessarily any obvious
better choice out of these two runs so i
can't look at them and say that
you know run one is wrong and run two is
correct right nor can i say that run two
is wrong and run
what run one was correct but neither of
those will give you the total order
anomaly
so recall the definition of totally
ordered anomaly or
or a violation of totally ordered
delivery is that
if a process delivers let's call these
m1 and m2
if a process delivers m1 and m2 then m2
like like our one did here
then all processes that deliver both
have to deliver m1 first
that's what a that's what a that's what
the definition of totally ordered
delivery is so a violation of totally
ordered delivery
is something like this where that
doesn't happen
so there's no violation of totally
ordered delivery happening down here
so i want you to notice that this
process r
has a whole lot of control actually on
when
to deliver messages so r is going to
establish the total order by deciding
when to deliver every message it gets
even if this message did show on
up up here r could say nah
i don't want to apply that update yet
i'm just gonna wait for a while
maybe i'll apply it after i get this
other one from client two why
i don't know maybe it's decided that
client one is more important
so it could establish a different order
from one run to the next
but doing so doesn't violate this
property of total order delivery
having the order be the same from one
run to the next
would be a different property and that's
called determinism
so determinism is a property that is
different from total order delivery
determinism
relates multiple runs of a system to
each other determinism
says that on every run you're going to
have the same outcome
so even if we have one replica we don't
have determinism
i'll say we don't necessarily have
determinism
so we do have totally ordered delivery
in this situation with one replica we
kind of have to
um but we don't necessarily have
determinism
i really i find determinism fascinating
um i studied determinism when i was in
grad school i wrote a dissertation about
it so
if you want to talk to me about
determinism uh i'd love to talk about it
um but that's not what totally ordered
delivery is and i think this is an
important distinction to make
so you know even if you have only one
replica like this
you can't guarantee that you're going to
get the same outcome every time unless
you impose some sorts of additional
stuff
so when there's only one replica it's
going to establish a total order on any
given run
what we would love what we would love
is to make it so there could be multiple
replicas but keep this nice
property of totally ordered delivery we
would like clients to be able to think
that they're dealing with a system that
does not have multiple replicas
that's what that's what uh that's what
strong consistency is
strong consistency is when clients can't
see that the data is replicated clients
can't tell that the data is replicated
so i want to spend a little time
uh talking about
uh some of the bad things that can
happen
when a client can tell that data has
been replicated
so in other words different ways in
which replicas could disagree
so here's one of the one of the really
obvious bad things that could happen
let's say we have our client let's say
we have two replicas
let's say the client does a write
and it could even get acknowledged
and then client does a read later
but they happen to do the read to the
other replica
my marker is running out let me get my
other one here
so the client happens to do the read to
this other replica over here
and who knows what r2 thought maybe it
thought that x was 4
or maybe it didn't have a value for x so
it would come back with 4. so the client
writes to r1
tells it that x is 5 gets an ok then she
tries to read x
and the read goes to some other replica
that thinks that x is something else or
may not even know about x
that might seem a little bit odd to this
client
so the property that is being violated
here is called read your rights
or ryw for short
it's one of the most fundamental things
that you might ask of any
distributed storage system but some just
still don't give you this
some systems still don't provide it
interestingly enough
here's another let's say that we have
two clients this time
and two replicas
and just to make this a little bit more
interesting let's let's pretend this is
a bank account
so we'll say it's a replicated bank
account maybe it's a joint bank account
so
here's our little picture of a bank here
so let's say that client one tries to do
a deposit
and she tries to deposit 50
and let's say that she gets an
acknowledgement
okay now let's say she tries to do a
withdrawal
and let's say that the withdrawals goes
to the same replica
so that's fine too
but let's say
that replica 1 and replica 2
are not being quite as uh
as conscientious as you might like
in sending these updates to each other
so let's say that this happens
let's say that r1 passes on this update
to r2
and it passes on this update
but they arrive in the opposite order
and just for good measure let's say that
we started out with zero dollars in our
account
so what's gonna happen over here on rep
replica two
negative money that's right
so client one did everything right
she waited for an acknowledgement from
the bank before she did her withdrawal
she made sure that she that the bank
acknowledged her deposit before she did
a withdrawal so client one didn't do
anything wrong here
but if client two were to come along and
do a balance inquiry inquiry right here
then the response right here in this
point right here
then the response would be sad
so the deposit and withdrawal got
flipped around between replica one and
replica two and if another client
happens to a read right at this wrong
moment
that client will see that the account is
overdrawn
by forty dollars
that's no good right what if this client
over here was actually some automated
process
that checks if accounts are overdrawn
and then charges overdraft fees
by the way banks sometimes do try to
reorder transactions in a way that's
beneficial to them in fact wells fargo
got in trouble for that a few years ago
they tried to manipulate
transaction order to maximize the
overdraft fees that they were charging
so anyway what kind of anomaly does this
look like here
with these messages crossing over
exactly yeah it looks like a fifo
anomaly
so this is a violation of fifo
consistency
so we can define fifo consistency this
way
rights done by a single process
are seen by all processes
in the order they were issued
in this case the rights were being done
by client one and the violation of
fifo consistency is that replica ii
didn't see those rights in the order
that client one issued them by the way
in this example
i could have left out client two here
and it would have still been
a violation of fifo consistency it's
just that having client two here
makes it especially obvious why this is
bad because
if there's another client who reads
these updates in the wrong order
then we're in trouble
all right so those are two bad things
here's another bad thing that could
happen
let's say again that we have two clients
and two replicas
let's say that the first client deposits
and gets an acknowledgement
okay let's say that client two over here
first checks the balance
and let's say that i ask that question
of r1 so let's say we started at zero
just like before here's our little bank
picture
so we deposited a hundred dollars now we
have a hundred dollars in the bank
client two asks about the balance
so this is a read right that one was a
right this one's a read we get back
our balance then client two
tries to do a withdrawal
and and gets back a message about there
being insufficient funds
so what went wrong here client two came
along checked the balance
saw that there was a hundred dollars in
the account and thought okay it's okay
to withdraw fifty dollars
they try to withdraw and then they can't
so what went wrong why did client 2
think they could do a withdrawal
yeah so client two
thought they could make a withdrawal
because they checked the balance over
here
the balance over here was a hundred
dollars why was it a hundred dollars
because of this earlier deposit so if
you follow the chain of events
and i'll even draw the arrows in red
here to make it really obvious
if you follow the chain of events here
you see that the deposit of
of 100 happened before in the sense of
of
that happens before relation this
deposit happened before
the withdrawal and so client two isn't
doing anything wrong
the problem is that replica 2
sees the withdrawal but it doesn't see
everything that was in the causal
history of it
remember how we talked about causal
history before the causal history of an
event
is every event that happens before it so
this withdrawal event is happening here
on replica 2.
but replica 2 hasn't seen all the events
that are in its causal history in
particular
replica 2 hasn't seen the deposit so
maybe replica 1 even tried to tell
replica 2 about the deposit but the
message arrived too late or something
like that
so this is a violation
of what we call causal consistency
so here's the definition of causal
consistency
so when i say rights that are related by
happens before i mean
the the translation of that is rights
that are potentially causally related
so rights that are related by happens
before meaning rights that are
potentially causally related
must be seen in the same causal order
by all processes
so i've just talked about a bunch of
different violations of different kinds
of consistency guarantees so all these
are
different consistency guarantees that
i'm talking about read your rights
consistency
fifo consistency causal consistency
and before i talked about strong
consistency so all these different
consistency guarantees i'm talking about
are progressively stronger
so we could draw a picture remember how
we drew a picture before uh where we
talked about uh
executions that observe different
delivery guarantees
we could do the same for consistency
so i could draw a venn diagram here
where i have a big circle with all
executions
within that i could do
[Music]
executions
observing
read your rights consistency
within that i could do executions
observing fifo consistency i see that i
didn't draw the circles big enough here
i'm going to run out of room
but you probably see where this is going
this circle here is going to be
causal so execution's observing causal
consistency
and then this one in here is going to be
strong
so hopefully that makes sense imagine
the words executions observing causal
consistency here and execution's
observing strong consistency here
so these are a bunch of different
consistency
guarantees that you could have in
increasing order of strength as you go
from
you know the all execution setting where
there's really there's no consistency
guarantee
to executions that have read your rights
consistency to those that give you fifo
consistency to those observing causal to
those observing strong consistency
and there are in fact more that i could
add to this picture if i wanted to many
more
in fact so there's a survey paper that
came out a few years
years ago which discussed something like
over 50 different notions of consistency
for replicated data now not all of them
are nicely nested like this in fact the
reason why i picked these ones to show
you is because these ones do have this
nice nesting
so i promise not to make you learn about
all those different 50
notions of consistency honestly they're
it's not that important for you to learn
about all of them
if you know about these you know four or
five here that should be good
so i'm bringing this up because i want
to emphasize
that different systems make different
consistency choices
so you might look at this and you might
think oh well strong is the best right
you know isn't this the one that's like
the one that i want but
you know maybe not
why would you maybe not want to go for
this very strongest level of consistency
possible
i'm starting to feel a little warm right
now i don't know if it's because of the
fever from the vaccine or because i just
love consistency models so
all right yeah so people are saying some
good reasons for why you might not want
to go for this very strongest
yeah so an issue is that
replicas could crash yeah certainly it's
harder to maintain strong consistency in
the presence of replicas crashing
and we'll talk a little bit more about
that later it takes more effort right
more messages have to get sent around if
you want to maintain strong consistency
so each of these different kinds of
consistency
gets harder to enforce and the more work
that you have to do to enforce them
the longer your client has to sit around
waiting
for you to get back to it with an answer
so you know one really nice thing if you
go back to this picture that we showed a
second ago of um
of a violation of read your rights
so here if you go back to this one here
where we were where we had this example
of this one client
two replicas in a violation of radio
rights consistency
now the client asked what the value of
four was and she got a request she got a
a response to her request right away she
didn't have to sit there and wait
for replica one to pass the data to
replica 2 and replicated with knowledge
replica 1 and all that nonsense
um and furthermore when she did this
initial write in the first place she
just got an okay back immediately from
replica 1.
now is this bad right like is this a
trade-off that you're willing to ask for
that replica 2's data might be a little
bit stale
for some people that's absolutely not
acceptable for some systems that's
absolutely not acceptable and you would
never want that
for some other systems it might be all
right and it's okay
if replica one kind of you know whenever
it has time it'll get the update over to
replica two but in the meantime it's
okay if
clients can't read their rights so this
is a trade-off that it makes sense to
think about
notice that this client is getting
answers back from
the data store really quickly here and
sometimes you know it's okay to get
an answer that's a little bit wrong as
long as it's fast
so you know it's the classic trade-off
do it right or do it fast
sometimes it's better to compromise a
little bit on the right
as long as you can have it be fast
so back to this picture
so if it's a trade-off
and if every one of these kinds of
consistency
uh forces you to trade off do it right
or do it fast
then you know what do you do right what
do you pick well
a lot of people think that causal
consistency is a pretty good compromise
so causal consistencies
doesn't give you everything that strong
consistency gives you but causal
consistency is often considered pretty
good
so this is what we're asking you to do
on the assignment
notice that some bad things can still
happen under causal consistency
and you'll see some of that maybe as you
work on the assignment but
it's kind of a pretty good compromise
and there are good reasons to want to
pick something weaker than strong
consistency so we'll talk more about
that as the course goes along
all right i think now is a good moment
to pause and do our quiz
so let's take a ten minute break and
let's return let's see what time is it
now
all right it's 409 right now so let's
return at 419
and i'll see you in 10 minutes
oh yeah so strong consistency so the
informal definition we gave last time
for strong consistency is
clients can't tell that the data is
replicated
and i think that's good enough the
question was did we go over a definition
for strong consistency
um
so there are more formal ways to define
this
but i think this is a good enough
definition is uh good enough for now
just out of curiosity i'm seeing like 60
viewers on twitch right now
um and i'm seeing considerably fewer
than that on
on zoom so are folks in the class
just choosing to use twitch instead
which is cool i'm happy to have you do
that
yeah zoom is laggy yeah
yeah i had some students in the past who
just refused to use zoom because it's
not free software
and i don't know how sustainable that is
i mean the
the surely the student was taking other
classes that classes that required them
to use them
but um
yeah you know folks who are
are uh dedicated to only using free
software
i respect that but uh there's
you know if you're using zoom in firefox
then you're still using zoom in the
cloud
so committing to not using
free software does that mean also not
using cloud-based
proprietary software i don't know
right
hmm
oh
all right two minute warning
all right it is 419 so let's resume
so there was a good question actually on
twitch chat
uh somebody asked are these consistency
models similar
to database consistency models in terms
of transaction semantics
um so that's a good question so i want
to be clear and say that we're not
talking about transactions here so
if this were a database course we'd be
spending most of our time talking about
transactions which is when a bunch of
operations either happen as a unit or
not at all
so that's actually not the setting that
we're really in here
and you don't have to think about
transactions or any of that for the
homework um and the the consistency
models that we're discussing discussing
here in this non-transactional setting
if you wanted to talk about transactions
i mean it's a related topic for sure
and all of this has a lot of overlap
with stuff that's discussed all the time
in the database world
um but um but these are considered uh
non-transactional consistency models
by the way um i realized that i've been
throwing around this word
models quite a bit and i don't know if
people know what the word means
so in particular i would call all these
things i would call read your rights
consistency fifo consistency causal
consistency and strong consistency
i would call them consistency models
and this word model is something that
i've used pretty often right we talked
about network
models earlier in the course we talked
about
fault models as well so
what is a model like what does that word
mean just out of
uh unrelated to any particular kind of
model like network models whatever what
is a model does anyone want to try to
define that word
hmm
now it doesn't doesn't have anything to
do with landport diagrams as such
so i would say that what a model is
yeah okay so this is good somebody says
a set of a set of behaviors or
expectations yeah okay
so yeah i would say that a model is the
set of assumptions that you have in mind
when you're building a system
so if we're talking about network models
we talked about two network models right
we talked about the
the asynchronous network model and the
synchronous network model each of those
is about an assumption
the synchronous network model is about
assuming that there's a bound on message
latency between
uh a sender and a receiver
the asynchronous network model is about
assuming there's no bound on network
latency
similarly fault models are a set of
assumptions about what kind of faults
what kinds of faults can occur and these
consistency models
are about a set of assumptions about
what kinds of executions can occur
so the question is if you're a client
and you're talking to a system you might
want to know
what can you assume and not assume about
the behavior of that system
and so it ca it it helps a lot if you
have this notion of a consistency model
that
will let you reason about what can you
assume about the behavior of a system
now with consistency models these
consistency models each describe
some set of executions and in this case
we're talking about
these nested uh sets of executions where
the um the kinds of executions that are
allowed under each consistency model
gets
smaller and smaller and smaller another
way to think about it
might be what clients are allowed to see
what clients are allowed to observe so
the consistency model tells you
something about
what kinds of bad things a client's a
client might be able to see
if you're if you've got um none of these
guarantees if it's just the all
executions then you could see all those
bad things that i talked about earlier
you could see a violation of
read your rights like an execution out
here could violate read your
rights it could violate fifo consistency
it could violate causal consistency it
could violate strong consistency
an execution here might violate fifo
or it might violate causal or strong
consistency but you won't see that
particular anomaly that i saw before
that's a violation of read your rights
so consistency models tell clients
something about what to expect
and that's what we mean by the word
model in general something about what to
expect from a system
what can you assume
all right let's move on to something
else
so before the exam
we talked about two replication
protocols that give you strong
consistency right so think back
to way back in those ancient times
before the exam when we talked about um
strongly consistent replication
protocols
and the two that we talked about were
primary backup
where you have a primary and some number
of backups and chain replication
where you have a bunch of replicas
arranged in a chain
so at the very end of last tuesday i
talked about how
both primary backup and chain
replication
are ultimately going to have to rely on
the presence of
some sort of coordinator process whose
job it is
to know who all the replicas are what
role they're playing
and keep everybody else informed of
those roles
and it also has to be able to detect
failures of the replicas
and when a replica fails it has to be
able to tell everybody
what the new configuration is going to
be
so for chain replication for instance if
let's say that we have
three replicas
it's going to be the coordinator's job
to know who is who
to detect failures and handle them
and it's going to have to tell clients
about who's the head and who's the tail
so you can imagine this other process
over here
i'll call it coordinator so this process
knows who's who
so it knows right now that the head
let's say is replica 1
and that the middle node is replica 2
and that the tail is replica 3. so this
is all state that the coordinator node
knows
so by the way
there's an assumption here that not all
of the replicas will fail
if you have n replicas
then there's an assumption that at most
n minus one will fail if they all
fail then you're completely hosed right
then forget about trying to store any
data or read or write any data
so when we're talking about fault
tolerance
we're talking about being able to
withstand some number of failures
and there's also an assumption that you
can actually somehow tell when a replica
has failed
so remember how we talked about fault
models a little bit before
um so we talked about the crash model
and then we said there was a subset of
that that was called the failstop
fault model
so before when we talked about crash
faults we said
when you have a crash fault that's when
a process fails by halting
so at that point it's it's no longer
sending or receiving any messages
but if you're somebody else
you don't necessarily know that a
crashed process has crashed right maybe
it's still running
but all the messages are to and from it
are just being lost
or no maybe they're just slow right
so when we're talking about chain
replication there's actually an
assumption
not only that processes can crash but
that we can tell that they've crashed
and that's what
what's known as the fail stop fault
model so if you think back to before
we we described the failstop model as a
model in which processes can crash
but we can tell that they've crashed and
this is kind of one step down
from the crash model so in the failstop
fault model
crashes can happen and you can tell that
that the process has crashed
in the crash model more generally
crashes can happen and you can't
necessarily tell
so to be more formal about it you could
say
in the fail stop fault model crashes
can occur
and can be
detected
i'll say by the environment
meaning other participants in the system
do you think that this is a realistic
assumption this assumption that
when a process crashes you can you can
detect it
all right we got a no in the chat
i would say yes and no right so what
could you do
to try to detect crashes and this is
something that you're going to have to
think about for the assignment right so
one thing you could do is maybe you can
ask every process
to periodically send you a message
saying i'm alive
and then if you've missed a few of those
in a row like if you
if you if it's been some time out right
and you haven't gotten that i'm a live
message which we could call a heartbeat
message
then maybe you declare it dead so
sometimes you're going to be wrong
it might still be alive but the i'm
alive message might have gotten delayed
so from time to time if you're taking
that approach
of making processes tell you that
they're alive every so often
from time to time you might declare a
process to be dead even though it isn't
and if you find that that's happening a
lot then you might want to increase your
timeout length
um but failure detection is its whole
deep its whole own whole deep topic that
we don't have time to talk about all the
details of um
but the short version is perfect failure
detection is impossible
so in an asynchronous distributed system
that is
in an asynchronous distributed system
where there's no bound on message
latency perfect failure detection is
impossible perfect would mean
every time those there's a failure you
see it and there's no false positives
right
no false negatives no false positives um
so every now and then you're going to
end up in this situation where you
declare a machine dead even though it's
not really dead and so
you're telling it you're dead and you're
dragging it away kicking and screaming
and it's saying no i'm not dead give me
another chance
so it turns out that that's
the fact of life in a in an asynchronous
distributed system sometimes you have to
declare something dead even though it's
not really dead
but we're assuming here that we can
detect failures
fail stop fault model so
yeah you can do it but it means that
some of the time you're going to be
wrong
so real quick in chain replication
let's say that r1 is the head process
here
and the head of the chain and let's say
that the coordinator sees that it fails
so maybe it's um maybe it's a protocol
where
all of the um the nodes in the chain
have to tell the coordinator every so
often
uh that they're live right let's say
that the
the coordinator sees that the head in
the chain has failed
what should the coordinator do
any guesses
if you happen to look at the chain
replication paper that i talked about
last
last tuesday then maybe you already know
the answer
broadcast to everyone that that replica
one is dead yeah okay so
what is it going to do with the
configuration of the chain though so
somebody's got to be the new head of the
chain if replica one is
is down right so what is the coordinator
going to replace replica one with
that's right yeah it's going to replace
it with the next in line so it's going
to take the head process out of the
chain
and it's going to make the successor to
it the new head of the chain
so in this case r2 would be the head of
the chain
there's no more middle node in this
chain
maybe later if another node gets uh
is brought up and then tells the
coordinator that it exists then the
coordinator can choose to splice it in
the chain
but at the moment this is just a chain
of two nodes which is perfectly fine
uh it's fine in terms of chain
replication working
um okay what about when a tail process
fails what if what if this one fails
then what does the coordinator do let's
say the coordinator finds out the tail
has failed
it's pretty similar to what happens with
uh with when the head fails
yeah that's right so if the tail
process fails the coordinator is just
going to take the tail
out of the chain and it's going to make
the predecessor the new tail so in this
case
we only had three to begin with and then
the head and the tail field so now
um r2 is both the head and the tail
which is fine actually we're down to
just one replica which is kind of no
good but in terms of chain replication
working it's fine
it just means that now all requests are
just going to go here
so it still works in terms of the chain
replication algorithm
it's maybe not great in terms of fault
tolerance and so at that point
you would hope that whoever the system
administrator is who's in charge here is
going to see that a couple of replicas
have failed
maybe they get a maybe they get paged
and um
and they find out that uh that all but
one replica is dead and they'd better
bring up another replica
okay so and what about when a middle
node fails then
its predecessor and its successor have
to be hooked up to each other in the
chain
but then there's no need to tell the
clients anything right because clients
don't care about the middle nodes in the
chain
um if the head and the tail fail however
the somebody's got to inform the clients
who they should be talking to
so in each case if somebody fails
and the coordinator finds out that
there's a failure then there's some
bookkeeping that has to be done
and that bookkeeping has to handle any
updates any rights that might have been
kind of part way down the chain at the
time that the failure happens
so i don't want to discuss that in any
detail because you won't be expected to
know it honestly
and if you're interested you can always
check out the chain replication paper so
if you care you can look up chain
replication
sorry i misspelled schneider there don't
want to
do him a disservice
they published this in 2004 i believe
um there's also a great paper that came
out uh not too long later
um which is called uh somewhat amusingly
object storage
on crack
craq the cr here stands for chain
replication
so i think this came out in 2009
this is kind of like a slightly more
modern take on chain replication if you
understand chain replication you can
understand this
uh so you can look that up if you're
interested in knowing the exact details
of what happens when a
when a process fails all right we got a
fantastic question in shot
what if the coordinator fails
what then and by the way
even though i've been talking about
chain replication this whole time
for primary backup replication there
also has to be a coordinator to handle
primary failures and backup failures and
make sure clients know who the primary
is so
we still have this problem what if the
coordinator fails
what the heck do you do that
what could you do to mitigate it what
could we possibly do to be more tolerant
of coordinator failures what do you
think
yeah we could we could assume defeat or
we could admit defeat right we could
just say sorry
no more rights no more reads oh
yeah everybody gets the day off uh what
if we want to do a little better than
that
what could you do to be more tolerant of
coordinator failures
well maybe somebody else could take its
place yeah okay but i mean these other
processes
they they might not have had all the
information that the coordinator had
though
so if it crashed everything that it knew
was lost right
let's say you're a note in the middle of
the chain you know who's ahead of you
and you know who's behind you but
you don't know everything else right you
don't necessarily know who the head and
the tail are
what if you're just the tail all you
know is who's previous to you in the
chain
you don't know who the head is
have backup coordinators yeah have a
bunch of coordinators so that's an
interesting idea
have a bunch of coordinators
change it to coordinators plural
uh oh but then those coordinators have
to be kept consistent with each other
wasn't that what we were trying to do in
the first place we were trying to do
strongly consistent replication
now it seems like in order to do
strongly consistent replication we have
to do
something to keep these consistent oh no
how are we going to do that
so this is actually the ideal lead-in to
our next big topic in this course
which is consensus
so it's very funny if you look at the
the chain replication
paper this 2004 paper that i mentioned
which is a fantastic paper by the way
it's
one of the classics of the distributed
systems literature
one thing they say is well we assume the
coordinator doesn't fail
so it's kind of like really you assume
the coordinator doesn't fail
and then if you kind of uh read a little
further they admit that that's an
unrealistic assumption
and then they explain that in the actual
implementation that they did
they have instead of one coordinator
process they actually have a small group
of coordinator processes that are
themselves running a consensus protocol
among them
to make sure that they agree with one
another and essentially behave as though
they're a single process
so i find this very interesting and a
little bit sobering
that if we want to have strong
consistency
of replicas which is what these
replication protocols like primary
backup and chain replication give
you if you want to have the strong
consistency and you also want to be
tolerant of false
which is probably the reason we were
doing replication in the first place
then ultimately we end up being reliant
on the consensus protocol and that
should give you pause
because consensus is hard and it's
expensive
so talk about reasons to not have strong
consistency remember this picture that
we showed a second ago
if you want strong consistency you're
going to have to deal with that you're
going to have to deal with that question
of coordinators
and that should give you pause because
then you have to deal with that question
of coordinators failing and then you
have to think about consensus between
different copies of the coordinator so
that's one reason not to have strong
consistency maybe
if you can get away with a weaker
consistency guarantee like causal
consistency then maybe you should
but there are times when you really do
need
strong consistency and there are times
when you really do need consensus
so we only have a little while left we
have let's see
about 13 minutes left we have time to
talk a little bit about consensus
so let's talk a little bit about that
when do you need consensus
so let's talk about a bunch of scenarios
that might come up when you're working
on distributed systems
so
these are all scenarios where you have
many processes a bunch of processes
so one possibility is you need to make
sure
they deliver
the same messages in the same order
sorry about that
all right so that's one possibility
okay here's another possibility you have
a bunch of processes
and you need them all
to know
what other processes exist
and keep those lists up to date so
whenever anybody dies or leaves the
group for whatever reason
then everybody's list has to get updated
or here's another possibility you have a
bunch of processes and you want one of
them
to play a particular distinguished role
and everybody else needs to know who's
playing the role
or here's another you have a bunch of
processes and you need them to be able
to
take turns getting access
to some resource that only one can have
at a time
maybe it's like a file or something
or maybe you have a bunch of processes
and they're all participating in a
transaction so i mentioned database
transactions a little while ago so maybe
they're all participating in a
transaction
and they need to agree on whether the
transaction is committed or aborted
these are all really hard classic
problems in distributed systems
and they all have names so this first
one
this is called the totally ordered
broadcast problem
whoops
sometimes also known as atomic broadcast
i think that name is a little bit more
confusing so i usually say totally
ordered broadcast
this one here is called the group
membership problem
and by the way this is very closely
related to what we talked about earlier
with failure detection
so if you need to know what processes
exist that's like knowing which
processes are
up
this one here you need one of them to
play a particular role and everybody
else needs to know about it
that's called the leader election
problem
this one you need them to take turns
getting access to something
that's the distributed
mutual excuse mutual exclusion problem
and then this last one here
this is the distributed transaction
commit problem
a lot of ink has been spilled in the
last 50 years
about how to solve all these problems
what do all these problems have in
common
well they all involve this group of
processes trying to coordinate with each
other and find agreement about something
so the thing that they're trying to
agree on varies right it could be
you know what order to deliver the
messages in whether or not a process has
failed
it could be who the leader is in the
case of leader election
it could be who is currently allowed to
access the shared resource in the case
of distributed mutual exclusion or it
could be
whether or not to commit in the case of
the distributed transaction commit
problem so
the details vary but all of these
different kinds of problems boil down to
the consensus problem
which is the problem of getting a bunch
of processes to coordinate and agree on
something
in distributed systems the thing that
makes this hard
is false and asynchrony
so remember how we talked at the
beginning of the course how distributed
systems
are systems where independent components
can fail
and you're going to have unbounded
latency right because we're in the
asynchronous network model so those two
things
make the consensus problem hard
so faults in particular what make this
hard i think so crash faults and
omission faults are the ones that
that we'll be considering the most in
fact mostly just crash faults because
it's hard
enough even then byzantine faults make
this extra hard we're not even going to
talk about that to be honest with you so
if you're interested in byzantine
consensus
that's a little bit beyond the scope of
this class something that you might want
to read about on your own
once you're once you're done with this
class
so we're going to spend a little time
talking about consensus and we're going
to be talking about a classic algorithm
for getting consensus um
we only have four minutes left today
uh but let me just try to before
obviously that's not enough time to talk
about
a consensus algorithm um but let's let's
just try to
to talk a little bit in very very high
level about
you know what it means to get consensus
so
let's say that you're trying to get some
processes to agree on something
and to make things simple
let's say that the thing that the
processes are trying to agree on
is one bit 0 or 1.
so every process has a say so we could
draw a box here
like this this is the consensus box
so every process gets to have a say
so they're all inputs to this box
and the consensus problem is to design a
protocol
so that the inputs go in maybe one
process is zero
another one says one another one says
one the consensus problem is to
design a protocol where everybody comes
out agreeing
either they all say zero
or it would also be fine if they all say
one
so that would be
another solution notice that
the consensus problem doesn't say
anything about what they agree on
the the consensus just says that they do
agree now you might look at this and you
might think well that's easy right
so one is the majority here so we should
go with one
but the trouble is keep in mind that
there's not some external person like us
we're like in
when we're looking down at this picture
we're like a god who has
perfect knowledge of everything that's
happening we see that these processes
say 0 1 1 and we can say oh well one is
obviously
obviously the majority so we can pick
one but these processes don't have
god-like knowledge of what each other
thinks so these processes have to
somehow coordinate among themselves in
this
consensus box and somehow come to a
point where they all agree
and they have to do it in the presence
of asynchrony and
failure it's really hard
so starting next time we're going to
talk about one of the best known
algorithms for what goes in this box
which is called paxos
and we're also going to talk about what
properties consensus
algorithms try to satisfy so we don't
have time to talk about that today
because we're out of time
but next time we're going to jump right
into paxos and it's going to be fun
all right i will see you on thursday
have a great next couple of days
you